let's go to our next caller from the
nine one four area code caller from nine
one four what's your name and what's on
your mind today
hi so my name is Gilliam I am a
university student at Bucknell out in
Lewisburg Pennsylvania but I'm
originally from New York we've been
watching your show for a long time and
one of the things that we've covered a
lot in in recent recent months has been
a lot of the output from the Trump
administration on referring to multiple
news outlets especially news that looks
like MSNBC and CNN as fake news it's
been everywhere and it's a point that's
been echoed by a lot of his supporters a
lot of Republican pundits etc etc right
especially within the past couple of
weeks what we've seen from a media
outlet I believe is a proc product very
calm US has put out some some videos
claiming to push this whole the whole
Russia conspiracy story as a big nothing
burger according to Van Jones as
basically for ratings and I think that
the way that this has been approached by
a lot of the Trump supporters we're
seeing is is this is a verification
that's not news and I bought a blog
whatever but I think it really does
touch on a much finer issue in that
compared to a Fox News which is very
easily seen or a Breitbart which is very
easily seen as a right-wing almost talk
show a right-wing I get to sort of
putting out that that sort of right-wing
agenda away right a lot of mainstream
media seems to rely on putting out
content to get ratings content to get
viewership yeah so did I I think I know
where you're going but in the interest
of time let me see if I could give my
thoughts because I I think you're
bringing up a really important issue
it's sad that the reaction to the CNN
producers saying it's for the ratings
has been well thus the entire Russia
story is fake news because I
hate to break it to you folks most
things that every corporate media outlet
does are for ratings I remember going on
well you know what actually I shouldn't
even say much more specifically but I
was once in a green room at one of the
major networks and it was around the
time of a plane crash and I witnessed an
identical conversation as to what
project Veritas revealed which was we're
going with the plane stuff again tonight
because it's doing really well in the
news now that didn't mean that the plane
crash objectively was or was not news
right all it meant was there were
editorial decisions me being made
based on what ratings could be expected
and that doesn't change that Jeff
session seems to have been deceptive
multiple times about which meetings he
did or didn't have with the Russian
ambassador right that is a fact that is
of objective importance no matter what
CNN does for ratings so I think dealing
you're you're spot-on in that there this
the entire fake news thing was
drastically distorted and confused by
that video so so is mainstream media
creating a larger issue here by seeking
up stories simply for reading oh I mean
listen that's not a new issue that's
being created the the fact that if it
bleeds it leads on local news the fact
that there have been questionable
relationships between advertisers and
corporate media for decades this is your
your right Dylan that this is a major
issue it's not a new issue and this is
what people have to understand any time
you're watching any program this
includes the David Pakman show right you
should understand what are the editorial
biases what are these structural biases
is there a bias towards sensationalism
what are the relationships with
corporations all of this stuff you're
absolutely right Dylan and I I
appreciate you calling in to to make the
point and ask that question because it
could not possibly be more relevant but
it's been relevant for a long time it is
not a new issue and I think that's a
really important thing to do to be aware
of